like so many of the rabid fans for the
chest comm computer Chess Championships
I had to make sure to check in to see
what would happen when LC zero took on
the engine leading the event last name
fish first name stock maybe you've heard
of him but the question was what could
the Queen herself Lila come up with when
playing the white pieces now as I said I
wasn't surprised to see the chat buzzing
during this marquee matchup but I was
surprised to see so many people still
there when the position seemed like it
was clearly petering out to a draw even
after Lila's move on the board
the last try being this h3 stab stock
fish still evaluated the position as
zeros and you don't argue with a man
that has a table base hooked up to his
many many many core CPUs or whatever
stock fish is operating on but I did
find the position really instructive and
I really respected Leela's last very
human strong Grandmaster ish way to
create one less pitfall one last
opportunity in which stock fish might go
wrong and to understand why I'm saying
that h3 is this opportunity we're gonna
hop over now to the bat-cave and let the
analysis board take us away I hope you
put on your I want to learn pants today
because we're about to stuff those
pockets full of knowledge so to start we
back up a single move and explain
exactly why white can't play the really
obvious move the move that any of us
would love to play if we can win a piece
for free against stock fish hey a queen
well strong players will immediately
recognize this position isn't even worth
calculating because the lone pawn you
have left is not queening on the color
of the color square that you need for
this Bishop to be useful in other words
it's a theoretical draw even up a piece
if you were to take away all of stock
fish's remaining three pawns white is
still not threatening to win due to the
fact that as long as this King reaches
the corner the bishop here is helpless
and the pawn being a corner pawn is
unable to force the King away from the
promotion Square that's the quick way to
describe the fact that you can't even
consider queening and letting black give
up the night for the pawn it's obvious
as well
probably black can come forward with the
King and force a trade of this pawn if
you want to so the first thing we've
established as far as a pattern and a
piece of knowledge we need to have in
this position to understand why Lila
played h3 is that we can never ever
expect to get a queen where this Knight
can give itself up and think we still
have a chance to win the endgame that's
number one so if that's the case what's
the second idea we might come up with
well given that the only chance we have
is still on the Queen side despite the
fact that we may not be able to win by
letting the knight give itself up we
know we really don't have any chances
for our one pawn to beat these three so
the other idea that comes to mind is
what if we try to run up the board to
remove this Knight from said critical
Square and then get a queen well some
quick math tells us that while this
seems like the most straightforward idea
probably blacks pawns are far enough
advanced to compete at least equally in
the race one line that makes that very
clear is that after King to see three
black pushes if we go all-in on this
idea black pushes again yes the bishop
can flex his muscles that he can move in
the open board much faster or more
powerfully than the knight the problem
is black has way too many pawns and
after h4 the King comes up we see
immediately moves like h3 suddenly the
bishop is overwhelmed as far as what
exactly to guard staying in front of the
F pawn being the only move that keeps
winning chances alive we see g3 we're
taking h3 what allow us to take h2
taking g3 would allow h2 and it's
actually black who's likely on the upper
side of things here so while we well
we've established yes we can't win if
we're gonna let the knight give up
there's probably very few lines where we
could actually bring our King forward
and successfully get this night away
from the pawn now if we could somehow
make it less easy for black to just
advance these pawns up the board if we
could somehow create some problems for
these pawns all of a sudden this idea of
bringing the King of becomes a viable
option now we see the move h3 come into
play and why I loved it so much as soon
as I saw Lee to play it I'm watching the
chat go crazy at this point and
considering that okay as much as this is
one nice idea
there's a reason stockfish had this
position at zeroes there's no way that
the strongest engine on the planet is
going to capture on h3 and and go for
the type of endgame that would be losing
why is it losing first let me show you
that after G takes h3 now that we've
created a situation where these pawns
are both on the same diagonal suddenly
we've put this bishop in a position to
be the most powerful piece on the board
this bishop is not only going to be able
to continue to help us threaten to get a
queen it's going to guard critical
squares for this night trying to get
active and it's also going to prevent
every pawn from pushing we no longer
have a situation with three connected
passers where the bishop can't stop them
we oppose that yeah there's three of
them but there might as well only be two
and our Bishop is ideally placed to deal
with them a variation that illustrates
this would be something like we bring
the king forward and if black tries to
stop white from from advancing you're
going to see that eventually zoogs one
occurs no matter what the King comes to
c4 the King comes to d6 currently a
blockade is set up but now the bishop
moves and we start to see the zoogs
won't take place
black will eventually run out of moves
and when he does the king will have to
retreat as we've already established the
knight has no options here to move
without the Queen if the King retreats
the white team comes up we can rinse and
repeat this process until we've
eventually established a 6-1 if the King
had gone to d8 or d6 the same thing
would have occurred with the King moving
in make a funny move with the bishop and
no matter where this King goes we put
our Bishop on c6 and you can see the six
Wang that has occurred key to note of
course as well as that these pawns don't
have any way to change this scenario the
main line I've analysed here of course
is that if the King went to c8 after the
bishop moves we eventually come in to c6
and as said black does research 1 so now
we've established three things very
instructive and important to understand
as you a human might become a better
ranking player forget about these
engines you'd love watching in the just
calm computer Chess Championships but
how can we approach end games at a high
there's no the only way to do it is not
by calculating these lines a million
moves a minute but by having a whole
bunch of positions that we know
theoretically because of the work we've
done because of videos we've watched
because of books we've studied and when
you're starting to become familiar with
this idea that a bishop has the ability
to outplay the night in the open board
and eventually put black and Zhuge swung
that allows you to see why something
like h3 is so creative and and such an
interesting way for leader to create a
pitfall right we already established one
reason why you have a database of
knowledge of patterns that this pawn
can't win if the bishop is the wrong
color corner so that we don't play moves
like this we've established basic
calculation that says we can't just come
forward willy-nilly we're not gonna win
but h3 maybe creates this opportunity
for effort for that to happen if
stockfish which sounds crazy to say if
stockfish blunders it's an oxymoron
sentence right
but when HTTP was played I fully
expected like everyone else that the
zeroes there was because any move that
doesn't take here literally any King
move the most obvious of which might be
something like King g5 bring the King in
to h4 and force the capture as this
would prevent I black from just winning
the pawn with the king and if something
like this occurs we can see in many
lines once again that the two pawns in
the King are going to be plenty fast
enough to prevent white from just
rushing forward but suddenly stock first
play G takes h3 hmm I'm thinking right
so I'm in chat right now and I'm still
seeing zeroes from stock fish still
seeing a lot of people in chat just
saying what's going on here what's the
point of this game continuing but I'm
flabbergasted and in my motive is there
something wrong with just calm server or
be sure stock fish is okay because I'm
suddenly seeing for the first time a
plan that might be winning for white and
indeed leah played the move came 2 d 3
and after h2 she came forward with the
move came to c4 I'm looking at a
position where not only is my Bishop
ideally placed and I'm familiar with
this pattern that I've even used to
winning games myself and Bishop for
Knight and stock fishes King isn't even
trying to attempt to blockade me so I
start calculating what if black plays
moves like h4 and
then eventually comes over I'm thinking
okay maybe I was just wrong blacks King
can't get there and stop it
but after moves like Bishop f3 again the
King moves we come into c6 at some point
the zoogs Wang will occur the pawns will
either just start giving themselves up
or you'll move your King away from your
night or your knight will move and I'll
get a queen so I'm not able to visualize
what in the world stockfish could be
doing and again I'm in full isn't
stockfish hook up to a table based mode
Oh Santi to shout out to the Jewish user
who I said I would do this video for I
don't lie and everybody else is saying
I'm crazy for thinking there's any
chances here Danny the table base says
zeros who are you to argue with such
information and and I agree I felt in a
very weird state I don't want to talk
about it right and then stockfish plays
the move came to g5 so I'm thinking from
a chess knowledge perspective of how
humans try to play like engines we apply
our own table base I don't have a table
base but I have a database of knowledge
and patterns that I'm familiar with
I'm thinking something very strange is
going on here especially when I actually
start to calculate thinking I was just
gonna check in on this before bed I see
a very very clear winning line for white
and we end up going down that line came
to c5 the King comes to g4 at this point
the only opportunity for black out of
desperation he must try to block the
diagonal of this Bishop in order to get
a queen but pretty straightforward
calculation says after a free White has
a nice tactic you can pause the video if
you want to find it but it's based on a
very common theme of putting your enemy
King on a mine square some call it a
land mine a bad square so that when you
get a queen it comes with check with
Tempe and that of course is to take your
would check first taking the knight
would allow black to get the clean right
so we take with check put the King on
this land mine Square now capture and we
immediately see that h1 queen would lose
on the spot skewer and ouch town for
stockfish but still I'm being told I'm
crazy because after king of 2a a queen
the table base and all the users are
saying this is a draw because the table
base says it so because doctor says it
so I can't disagree at this point with
the zero is still very skeptical I've
actually pinged team members in our
slack room like is everything okay with
the C
because I'm looking at this position
with the database of knowledge in my
head that there is a very very
well-known pattern that says yes the
corner pawn is normally a draw if you
take this pawn off
I surely agree with you but there are
very very common trips that occur
whenever your opponent has an extra
pollen that allow you to win to
illustrate that point I'm actually going
to just set up the position here and
show you that if we were to for example
be able to put our Queen anywhere like
this square here g3 okay with black to
play now you say this is still a draw
and this was the point I was trying to
illustrate illustrate for us on t2 and
the rest of the chat that obviously you
can't go here because now I win the pawn
in the game so your move is king - h1
well the issue here is a very important
trick that like I said I'm stuffing your
pockets full of knowledge here so get
ready whenever your opponent has an
extra temple move of any kind the corner
pawn does not draw because of a
well-known mating trap you move the
Queen a Knights check away no matter
what square the pawn goes to I don't
care what pawn it is on the board they
have to make a move zib swung and you
checkmate them on f1 as long as your
Queen can reach the square that I'm
setting up here right where the king is
in check sorry after the King goes to h1
as long as the Queen can reach this
Square where the King has to go here
this is a this is a very very common
mating net so now we go back to the
position of the of the game and ask
ourselves
oops sorry about that we're gonna back
up and actually we're just gonna reset
it here we're gonna add it to be white
to move and we're gonna reset it back to
the game and we're gonna so why was I so
crazy well I had no idea that this was
one of those rare positions where for
some reason based on the position of the
pawn I actually can't get my Queen to
this magic square in the game Lila
illustrated this by playing a million
and a half checks bringing the Queen
exactly where I would have brought her
eventually behind the pawns and suddenly
you see that because we don't have this
check
we have no ability to force the King
away from the critical squares we can
check around all we want but we can't
get directly behind the pawn so here's
where things get exciting and where my
mind continues to be blown hence the
thumbnail if that's what brought you in
here
I proclaim well okay I was wrong yes
you're right that I I said that there
was something wrong here this is a win
for white and the twitch users are
having a field day making fun of me very
fun but I said well this was just
clearly one exception of a position
where the table base had a huge
advantage for stockfish / Leela because
of the fact that stockfish just knows
this is a draw and Leela isn't able to
calculate that she's thinking about it
more like me right we know that she
plays more like strong grandmasters not
that I am one than any other engine on
the planet but there was just this one
exception that you can't really hold
against her or me then all of a sudden I
I made this proclaim felt pretty good
about it left it my wife's mad at me at
this point I keep talking about Leela
and how amazing she is wyfy wants to
know who is Leela I have a mistress
what's going on right so I got to go
save my marriage and as I'm saving my
marriage of course I still can't get
that lady out of my head as we're going
to sleep at night and the reason is that
I realized not only was I wrong once for
claiming that stockfish was winning
they're sorry that alia was winning and
the sake of Leonard I was wrong again in
saying that this is the only exception
to show that I move to our next port
where I've actually just put the pawn
we'll just uh we'll set it up again
I put the pawn one square further up and
again shown that yes the pawn on h5 is a
draw but obviously a pawn on h4 must be
a draw too because it guards the square
put this clean on any imaginary square
you want she gets to g4 whatever the
point is we can't get to g3 so now I'm
really feeling like a like a silly goose
forget that Mouse slip right there as
I'm going to sleep at night thinking of
all of the users saying okay well okay
so there's there's two exceptions
obviously before I move on there's got
to be a third exception because with the
pawn on h3 we don't have the ability to
play Queen of - it would be stalemate so
if we're in a position like this clearly
it's also a draw because we don't have
the ability to play Queen of two without
the game ending peacefully
so now I'm thing okay well I've
certainly solved the fact that that
means I have a new pattern to add in my
database normally I'd be right that the
extra pawn doesn't up the corner pawn
but if the pawn is advanced at least to
h5 that means all three of these pawns
are a draw and that should be good
enough no other pawns would be a draw
right right well obviously not what if
the pawn has advanced far enough on the
G file right I start recognizing that
here any sort of series of checks that
we can do to get close I you know what
what is it gonna be eventually it's
what's it all about Alfea right we get
here and how do we get closer we can't
which should be obvious one that's when
I actually knew so now I realized I was
wrong again mine continued to be blown
and I'm here to just own on my own right
shame that I spoke to you quickly that
so obviously with the G plum being there
I had to ask well does the same rule
apply to the G pawn I just established
that I didn't realize the pawn on h5 was
far enough to prevent this theoretical
trick what about the pawn on g4 if we
take away the legal moves and you know
let's set up a new position for all of
us here well it looks like this one
should also be a draw because the only
way we can inch our way behind a corner
pawn is usually to use the checks behind
the pawn so let's use our let's use our
queen and let's let's just you know
check a doodle here and get as close as
we can and we realize how frustrating it
is that we're never threatening to take
this pawn with check because then we've
gotten rid of our only advantage which
is the fact that they have to move our
extra pawn while we checkmate them so
this one should also also be a draw what
about the fifth rank for the the the G
file well here I'm happy to say that I
wasn't totally crazy or so so
ill-equipped that to say that I didn't
know that this one is is a win this one
is indeed a win specifically because as
I said we now have the ability I'm
thinking this in my head I'm thinking
out loud right now we have the ability
to get behind the pawn and the main
reason is that you can't voluntarily
still make yourself yet even though the
pawn is stuck because I can go here
allow you to push I can go here allow
you to push and we have this checkmate
very important pattern to know of
everything we're talking about right but
if we go back a
okay and you don't you don't voluntarily
steal mate but move over now we can do
the trick that we've been looking for
all along which is to force the King to
the bad square we go to the magic square
and get our mating net so when it comes
to the G pawn and the H pawn I now have
improved my knowledge thanks to stock
fishin Lila and I'm feeling a lot better
about myself surely there's I don't
think there's anything really more to
learn as far as pawns that I maybe
didn't know we're theoretical drawers
and then all of a sudden I thought of
the pawn on f4 and I realized yet again
I was wrong how does white win this game
and I'm sitting there up all night
thinking about this and this was last
night I can't stop thinking about this
game because I'm like it's just I made
all these probably the embarrassment
right and I realized that there's
another way that black drawers based on
the fact that this pawn is guarding the
critical square so another unique
potential set up a variation I've
already shown that the Queen can inch
your way forward yes but remember we can
never take the pawn with check and when
we get to this position of forcing the
King in front of the pond with this
check we can't play that check right so
there's another pawn I didn't realize
was actually a draw I believe for sure I
should have gone far enough now writing
at this point I'm thinking about the I'm
thinking about the the users and I'm and
I'm thinking that okay you know I'm
completely crazy at this point the
engine evaluation was correct from the
very beginning stockfish was right
what's going on right in the in the
world today and what have I actually
learned from this there must be that
must be it only only the F pawn could be
far enough right and then all of a
sudden I thought of one last problem
with my theory the one you see in front
of us the e font
how do we win with the e pawn let's say
that we're able to work our way all the
way to the g3 square now when they came
moves we still don't have our critical
square of F to any sort of checks taking
the pawn we know doesn't work anything
that doesn't force the King in front of
the pawn Queens so now I thought okay
this
like this is really unique and I've
gotten myself in a pickle where there's
a number of pawns I just wasn't aware of
and this is including the fact that I
never should have said it to begin with
because technically every pawn along the
second rank is also a one exception
right because you don't have time to
still make them when they're getting a
Queen so I've really even my words here
in my head as I'm sleeping last night
and then I realized wait a second
there's one last idea that you might be
able to play for only with the e pawn
and it's because the Queen actually
guards the square with check you have a
new idea to consider which is that if
you're able to get that King as far away
as it seems just close enough you might
actually be able to do the rare thing
and the normal the traditionally way the
only way you ever have winning chances
against a corner of Bishop on which is
is there some tricky way for your King
to get close enough to allow promotion
and then mate the king or queen well in
thinking of that in my head I was
finally able to go to sleep when I
realized that this particular position
was just one of those because White's
Queen is guarding a promotion square
notice there's nothing else for black to
do because the King is still made it so
this line is forced and with the checks
we get the King to f4 just in time and a
very common idea many people know after
the Queen we give a check of course
moves like King to h3 get the King made
it in the corner self made it or trapped
by his own pieces and the move King to
g1 allows came to g3 and we have a trap
where the Queen is unable to give any
checks and the black king will be mated
within the next move or so so what did
we learn from all this what we learned
is a few things number one never doubt
stockfish when he's got a table base
hooked up to his head the eval is
correct no matter what number two don't
proclaim single exceptions the thing
when rules are made to be broken there
may be many exceptions and we're all BIR
always reminded that we have more to
learn and I improved my ability to know
the patterns of how I would evaluate
these types of can be very tricky
endings where both sides are trying to
Queen if you don't have patterns in
those types of endings that you're
relying on you're dead in the water
anyway because usually you can't
calculate enough to keep up with the
position it's very difficult in any
games to calculate those kind of lines
especially when you think of a practical
where you might be under time pressure
and then finally I learned that the
twitch chat is always right trolls or
not the collective twitch trolling is
usually correct and in this case I was
wrong to challenge them and so I bow
down were my twitch shirt just for you
here and jokes aside shout out to
everybody that have fun hanging out with
I hope that at this point we can all
appreciate that there is now a
resolution to the fact that these types
of positions we will actually will clear
the board and reset these types of
positions with a corner pawn are indeed
a draw okay and even when we add pawns
back onto the board there are a number
of exceptions to this mating trick I
showed and I'm highlighting every single
one of those squares for you now careful
not to highlight the e3 Square that
taught me this valuable lesson so if you
end up watching this video and decide
that Danny you're still wrong ups one
more square Danny you're still wrong you
can also have a pawn on X Square and
it's a draw please leave a comment and
let me know but I'd like to believe that
after a long night lonely night where I
was thinking more about Lila than my own
dear sweet wife I actually did
eventually learn the lesson of how many
different exceptions there are to that
stalemate / mating net idea that I know
in my head and I will never again spend
too much time claiming things that I
don't know I want to thank everybody for
tuning in again leave a comment if I if
I missed one thing apparently I've got
more to learn about these things and
we'll see you around on chess calm and
at the chess calm computer Chess
Championship